I've always used the term all my career
Mentalist because I don't consider
myself a psychic I have no especial
supernatural powers what have you but
I've always felt it was possible even
when I started performing and that was
long as about 12 years old there was
possible under certain conditions to
perceive a person's thought we're seeing
it happened less and less in recent
years because our culture as the
traditional culture is disintegrating
and I've spoken before so many many
professional groups and sociologists
agree with me people are not
communicating anymore they're relying on
a box or a machine in their hand and of
course we now find this our level of
education in this country has plummeted
and that education is very important to
me I've done over a thousand university
shows but people don't hear each other
anymore there are actually human beings
and this is gonna seem incredible when
they're in a restaurant have a cell
phone on the table and we're looking
into it and I don't and I have nothing
against cell phones and what-have-you
because it's an important form of
communication but it's telling us
unconsciously how we feel about the
person across from us we don't really
value them that much because we're not
paying that much attention to them
people talk to us just as much when
they're not speaking we need to listen
to society and not be afraid of silence
and there are people who reached a point
where there are afraid of silence I mean
when you go into their house have a
television on and a radio on and you
begin to realize that they really can't
live unless there's something busy
around them I mean God if you if you're
not taking your kid on hikes you don't
have to have money but just on hikes
into the forest and listen to mother
nature because mother nature is talking
and sometimes when you listen to mother
nature you can hear voices and it isn't
really that they're speaking to you it's
your unconscious is turning things
around
picking up certain sounds that remind
you of something that's maybe in the
back of your mind
do I believe it's possible to perceive
us all yeah and there's certain
conditions yes for providing a person
concentrates